give them Lala you are back in our lives
cm7 can you believe it we're adults
easin does a random while you're doing
this no my man and I are doing extremely
well now that his divorce has been
finalized we are out there
we're open and I can finally say what
his name is
it's Randall let's talk about your man
let's do cuz you finally get to talk
about him on the show no I love that
were you excited nervous to finally go
there I was nervous just because of all
of the like hate that I've gotten in the
past but also it felt liberating because
it takes a lot of energy to constantly
call someone like my man my man my man
it's like a lot of work you know so to
finally be able to talk about my life
outside of my friendships with you know
my cast members is so refreshing you
know because he he hangs out with my
cast members as well we like motivation
together so I think it would be
difficult for everybody at this point to
like call him your man we can say
Randall you can say Randall now can you
give me the CliffsNotes of the love
strike we didn't get to learn how you
guys met how you fell in love how you
know he was the one so walk me through
everything um he actually came into Sur
one night that we that I was hostessing
and he was having a his holiday party
there and he sent his assistant up to me
to ask for my managers number because
they were casting for a film called the
RO hey Adam how nosy like almost three
years ago this happened okay and I went
in for multiple auditions in each time
he was like the jokester and I was like
he's cute like the way like I never
dated anybody like him but I like
whatever he's about I'm feeling I'm not
gonna fight it and then from there we
met up in New York it's like three
months after we had done the audition
process and I let him hit it first night
and the rest is just history now we're
engaged now you're engaged yeah we get
to see that no you don't see the actual
but I do talk about it this season and
the thing about it is the way it is in
my memory is so perfect it's just so
near and dear to my heart and I'm I'm
happy that it was just the two of us you
know right a private moment everything
in your life it's to be private anymore
how much Randall are we gonna get to see
on the show you don't see him at all
okay because he camera shy is that why
he's not a part of the show is that his
decision um yeah I think he's just a
behind-the-scenes type of person I think
he likes to keep certain things behind
closed doors but that totally works cuz
I like being the star unlike say the
background baby with where's my camera
where's the lighting how did you know he
was the one honestly I knew I was gonna
be with him forever when we had first
done the Dean and then I got into the
bath and I was broken out at that time I
had the worst weave in the world and I
get out of the tub fresh face and he was
like you're the most beautiful person
I've ever seen and to me that meant like
because clearly I was not physically the
most beautiful part of everything but I
was like okay I feel like I can be
myself with this person I had never felt
that before I always felt like I had to
like be on 24/7 and he just like lets my
crazy fly and he just deals with me like
a champion he reminds me and it sounds
so weird cuz I don't want to be that
girl that's like he reminds me of my dad
but he does my mom treated like over my
dad treated my mom like a queen and I
just like I found that quality because I
just adored my dad so much did your dad
get to meet Randall he did so before he
passed
Randall had called him and asked for my
hand and my dad was like I wouldn't have
it any other way and it was just like
the best feeling in the world to know
that my dad before he passed away could
give his stamp of approval I was gonna
say what did that mean to you probably
everything everything you know because
my dad was such a prominent part of my
life and just hung the moon in my eyes
so for him to give the okay Duran to
like take his baby girl it was just like
the
you couldn't have planned it more
perfectly I just really adore my fiance
for even thinking about that cuz it's
like I don't know if most men do still
call and write ass Jackson Britney were
just here and they were saying that you
are not quite in the wedding planning
stage yet know why not
I'm the worst bride-to-be ever right
like for me I'm just like so enjoying
being a fiance I feel like there's that
stage of like you have a boyfriend when
are you getting married the proposal
when you know you get married and then
it's like when are their kids I just
want to enjoy for a minute
I think 2020 is one okay I will tie the
knot that would be she's a nine uh
Vanderpump rules
correct would you document the wedding
on the show no no I would not document
the wedding on the show why not I just
don't want any outside opinions of
something so close to my heart if that
makes sense I just want that moment to
be sacred for everybody that's actually
involved okay you mentioned babies I
know Randall has a couple kids yes what
do what's Lala the stepmom like she's so
fun um because I get to I get that role
of like you can feel safe with me but we
can also like have the best time ever
cuz I'm not your parent you know Randall
and and the mom do such a great job of
raising them so I let them handle that
part and then I'm the one that's like
here have some lip gloss it's the want
to do fake nails we can do think nail
the eight year old asked me every single
day can I have your new give them while
a beauty I'm like Carl we need to get
you an Instagram so you can promote
raising a little influence I totally
have you and Randall had the
conversation of more kids for the two of
you yes he said on one I'm set on - so -
it will be because while I gets what she
wants okay
but there's no timeline in place for
that right now um I would like to get
married in 2020 and then at least a year
of being married and then let's let's
get it poppin daddy